注意一句話 做AI簡報們的AI已經全部被Google判了死刑
以前大家碰都不碰的Google slide
最近推出了一個極度重大的更新
現在他已經變成Nano Banana Pro的形狀了
現在你只要一鍵按下去 你看這些簡報兩個字扯爆
嗨各位又是我AJ
Google slide這東西在這個遍地都有AI做簡報的時代
連我其實之前是不太用的 但是這個情況在nonobananapro發表之後
迎來了180度的大翻轉
Gemini大手一揮
直接把nonobanana Pro放到了Google slide里面
我們來看幾張比如說像這樣這樣這樣
都是用按的 這個簡報就直接做出來了
今天我們一次帶你把剪報大綱秒變成超質感剪報
你說剪報大綱怎麽來的
當然是使用傳譯寶APP
市面上最好用的語音APP
讓我無痛直接將brainstorming的會議內容變成簡報大綱
想學的朋友我們來看這一集 AI時代改變這麽快
一定要有拿得出手的壓箱寶
感謝本集的冠名夥伴傳譯寶APP
幫你把繁瑣的日常直接高效進化
首先我們來到熟悉的這個Google首頁那這一次我們在Google應用程式里面
你可以直接找到Google簡報 進來Google簡報之後 你可以直接按建立新的簡報
然後這邊然後你應該就會看到這個slide的BETA 進來之後呢
你就會看到右邊這邊出現一個這個叫做幫我繪圖的banana的這個圖示
這邊就會出現一個投影片 幫我做一張簡報
內容是跨年可以做的事情
所以你看圖好了把它點下來
然後這邊按一個以新投影片的形式插入
你看大標題有做出來 里面的小標然後里面的配圖
然後里面的這些小圖示 完美
如果你對於這樣的一個風格這個不喜歡
那你就可以直接跟他說幫我換一個風格
比如說幫我換成有聖誕氣息的風格 一樣生成以下的這個簡報的內容
他就會幫你去做這樣那個簡報的生成
然後一按了一下之後 以新投影片的形式插入
你會發現說我就插了一個新投影片
而且現在加上了聖誕風格 他會幫我加上這些聖誕裝飾
那接下來 我們要來分享一些比較進階的這個提示詞生成的技巧
創建一個新的Google slide的時候
其實他會有一些提示詞的風格在這邊
比如說我要這個Y2K復古未來主義 那我就寫重覆使用這個提示詞
他就會幫我去好做風格的定義
還有字形
顏色背景等等這些描述
那我就把這些Google官方提供的提示詞作為範例提示詞提供給AI
好那這個簡報內容大綱
我們是從這個傳譯寶APP里面會出的一些會議的這些內容討論
那比如說我們這些主題要教的是怎麽樣談NotebookLM我把這些內容複製下來
然後我的簡報內容大綱長這個樣子 然後我就可以去
有了 透過這個方式你就可以批次的生成
大量的一張一張一張圖片提示詞
而且每一張圖片的風格都可以維持一致
所以製作一張Y2K復古風格
然後我就把它貼上來然後按送出
新投影片插入 重新定義筆記認識Google NotebookLM 是不是非常的厲害
注意喔你在做這樣那個生成的時候
你還是要一張一張的把那個圖片生成的提示詞把它放進去
這個投影片的這個模式
所以這樣做出來了而且還是y2k的這個風格的
然後中文字看起來沒有什麽太大的問題
我們之前有一支影片教到我們在Gemini的canvas里面可以做到簡報風格的生成
在Google里面用這個canvas來去製作簡報 比如說我制作一份投影片主題是
好所以你看我們現在獲得了一份這個簡報
然後我們就這樣匯出成簡報
那你這時候就會看到我的簡報下面出現一個按鈕叫做美化這張投影片
我們就給他按下去
他就會幫你把你現在做好的字很多的投影片進行美化 好
那這樣跑出來的結果
很明顯的就是他做了美化給我了一張適合的圖片
然後他在文字的這個前面都加上了emoji icon之類的這些東西
但是美化後 這字就固定的 很簡單你就直接點這張圖片
然後直接再一次的選擇編輯這張圖片 請幫我移除圖片當中的所有中文字
並且保持圖片設計不變
非常完美的獲得了一張乾凈的背景
好那你就自己把字
再重新搬過去這樣子 就做完了 資料就過來了
那你要怎麽樣維持這個簡報風格的一致性
你可以簡單的選下頁投影片
然後就直接跟他講說請參考上一張投影片的風格
幫我美化這張投影片
我們自己測下來其實他的這個風格維持的那個穩定性做的非常非常的好
所以你看這是原本的長這樣
美化過長這樣是不是非常非常厲害的
那如果你覺得他生成這些東西你不喜歡的
那你可以按這個上面有一個按鈕叫做清除記錄
給他勇敢的按清除
在這個模式之下你的圖片生成那個對話串就會被清掉
所以你就可以重新去設定你要的那個圖片的風格
最後給要提醒各位的事情就是 右邊這邊這次生成你不滿意
你沒有在這個時候按插入或者是你在這地方按了清除
那這樣圖就會消失
所以只要看了你覺得還行的
我建議各位都把它全部放進來了
放進來之後 你到時候要刪你到時候再去刪就好了
來跟各位分享一下
我們在做的時候其實我們會發現說當你剪報上面的字不夠多的時候
他就沒有這個功能沒有這個按鈕
你的投影片裡面要有75個字元
不要問我為什麽是75
我們試出來就是75不多不少 少了你就看不到這個美化這張投影片
另外一個就是他在生成的這個結果
你沒有辦法去做一些細節的調整
那再來我們在測試的時候還有發現第三個狀況
就是表格里面的字他不會理你 不知道為什麽會這樣
但總之就是你必須要用文字框的形式 去存放文字在簡報上
美化簡報這個按鈕才會有用
好最後一個小技巧 就是你會覺得說這提示時是不是都寫的太簡單了
那有沒有在更進階點的提示詞
我們的好朋友Gamma 現在進入一個叫做工作室模式
簡介好了 好那我們來一些背景資訊 生成大綱
那在Gamma的這個新版的工作室模式之下
他其實也整合了那麽把Nano Banana Pro的圖片生成的模型
但是問題還是一樣的就是他是生成圖片所以圖片里面是不能改字的
那怎麽辦
好我們按生成 這張簡報我喜歡那我要怎麽樣在Google里面重置這份簡報呢
我只要點一下這張圖片點兩下右邊就會出現他的圖片生成的指令
你就直接把這個圖片生成的指令全選
然後回到我們的Google簡報里面
然後我們就直接把這個提示詞放進來使用你看這樣就做出來了
好以上就是我們今天這期影片
不知道Google slide有沒有重新燃起你製作投影片的沖動呢
那非常歡迎你在影片下面留言
跟其他的網友分享一下製作投影片的心得還有技巧
那我們今天的影片就到這個地方拜拜